das geht hier ist Luca
ich habe glaube ich noch nie ein
komplett ungeschnittenes Video auf
meinem YouTube-Kanal hochgeladen und
erst recht habe ich noch nie ein Video
aus dieser Perspektive hier hochgeladen
das ist mein Schlafzimmer
also das ist ein Wäscheständer das ist
ein Bild und das ist mein Fernseher und
da ist ein kleiner aber das hier ist die
basically mein Schlafzimmer deswegen
ganz kurz die Info für euch warum steht
im Titel vorerst Pause das bezieht sich
tatsächlich auf mein video output hier
auf Youtube ich ähm bin gerade im Urlaub
wenn ihr dieses Video hier seht ich bin
gerade an der Nordsee einmal im Jahr
haben wir immer im Sommer mit der
Familie an die Nordsee und da sind auch
viele Freunde von mir und so und da
freue ich mich schon extrem drauf Wetter
soll wissen durchwachsen aber es ist
immer komplett egal da weil man halt mit
anderen Leuten da sonst immer schön und
da fahren keine Autos auf der Insel man
hat so eine schöne Luft und kann da
super entspannt und so da freue ich mich
wirklich extrem drauf dementsprechend
werde ich auch jetzt in den nächsten
zwei Wochen bin ich nämlich da wenn ihr
dieses Video hier seht weniger hochladen
ich habe ja zwei Youtube Kanäle einmal
mein Hauptkanal wo dieses Video gerade
kommt und mein zweitkanal Luke Schuh der
auch übrigens kurz vor einer Million
Abonnenten steht könnt ihr gerne mal
vorbeischauen ist unten in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt auf diesem
Kanal die kommen ja Videos die ich
komplett schneide ich habe ja keine
riesen Team bei mir im Hintergrund mit
redaktionsassistenten und
produktionsleuten und cattern und
Sammler Assistenten und riesenmanagement
Teams das habe ich alles nicht wie
andere Youtuber Influenza Streamer äh
sondern ich mache das ja eigentlich
alles noch allein und ähm auf meinem
zweitkanal hingegen habe ich dann
Kollegen da hier aus Hamburg der mir
hilft aber den äh Videos mit dem
schneiden etc deswegen werden da
tatsächlich in diesen zwei Wochen genau
weiter die Videos laufen immer drei Tage
lang in Folge ein Video dann einen Tag
Pause 3 Tage Video einen Pause ist schon
immer so gewesen auf dem zweiten Kanal
wird auch immer noch weiter so bleiben
wir haben coole Videos da geplant wie
ich beispielsweise darauf reagiere wie
eine McDonald's Big Mac Produktion
aussieht wie ich versuche zu erraten
Probleme nur Mädchen haben die Jungs
nicht verstehen sind coole Videos
geplant auf jeden Fall deswegen schaut
auf jeden Fall vorbei auf den zweiten
Kanal geht alles normal weiter aber hier
auf dem Hauptkanal werden nur alle drei
bis vier Tage Videos kommen die nächsten
zwei bis drei Wochen und ich weiß dass
das bei anderen Youtuber normal ist das
ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung oder jeder
so hochladen möchte um Gottes Willen
allerdings ist es für mich extrem
schwierig zu sagen ich mache jetzt
Urlaub
und das ist für mich ein Zeichen gerade
dass ich wieder kurz vor einem Burnout
stehe
ich möchte keinen Mitleid ich mache
dieses Video hier auch nicht damit jetzt
irgendwelche 40-jährigen
Utes hier sagen oder redet über Stress
der Macht YouTube-Videos den Stress
hätte ich gern
also ich dachte nicht so echt komplett
egal was sie sagen oder denken ich weiß
einfach nur dass die letzten Wochen und
Monate für mich sehr sehr voll waren
sehr sehr prall gefüllt und das ist
gut so natürlich man freut sich wenn das
Business läuft wenn ihr euch an den
Content erfreut wenn die Zahlen super
sind oder sind sie ja seitdem ich das
hier mache seit zehn elf Jahren deswegen
ich bin euch ja unendlich dankbar dass
ich das hier mein Beruf nennen darf
diese dumme Kacke ich kann jetzt in die
Kamera furzen und dir feiert das ist wer
hätte das dem 12 jährigen Luca mal
gesagt da wollte der mit 12 Volt was
wollte ich werden wahrscheinlich
Astronaut oder so ein Scheiß mit 17
wollte ich eigentlich direkt werden mit
80 und Youtube angefangen mit 20 wollte
ich dann nämlich dann gesagt ich bin so
happy mit meinem Job 27 und ich kann mir
nichts besseres vorstellen naja auf
jeden Fall ist es so dass in den letzten
Monaten so viele Projekte anstanden so
viele Sachen passiert sind ich habe so
viel gearbeitet gemacht getan aber viel
Sport gemacht und so und das alles
natürlich Stress dazu kommt immer auch
noch positiver Stress was geht ja nicht
nur den Stress von wegen Arbeit und
Sport und dies und das das gibt doch
positiv von Stress wenn du dann abends
mit Freunden draußen unterwegs bist das
ist natürlich cool das macht Spaß
hier irgendwie mit jemandem zusammen
Horrorfilm gucken habe ich letztens
gemacht der boah das war natürlich jetzt
das Chillen man liegt im Bett mal gucken
Horrorfilm zusammen aber es ist jetzt es
ist jetzt wirklich auch keine
Entspannung und ich bin halt so ein
Mensch ich habe übelst homo weiß nicht
was das heißt es die Abkürzung für vier
auf missing out also ich habe Angst
davor irgendwas zu verpassen wenn wir
jetzt Freunde von mir schreiben wenn ich
fahre morgen früh oder wenn wir jetzt
Freunde schreiben hey nebenan wir sitzen
hier am Platz haben wir Kiste Eistee
zocken eine Runde Fußball ich bin dabei
los geht's Video Ende so die Sache ist
aber das ähm mir dann einfach dieses
Gefühl gezeigt hat luca du stehst wieder
kurz vor Burnout weil ich hatte ja mit
21 so Bernhard Erscheinungen wo ich
meine Bachelorarbeit hatte ich hatte
also ich war noch ein Studium
die kann nebenbei gemacht ich habe
Youtube Videos hochgeladen und und top
wollte ich halt auch immer was mein
kommiliton machen mit meinem
Studienkollegen etc also ich habe mich
nie zurückgenommen und wirklich mal
hingelegt und geschlafen wirklich
wochenlang am Stück nicht mehr als sechs
Stunden Schlaf pro Nacht und das war
jetzt in den letzten Wochen Monaten
wieder sehr häufig so der Fall sieht
irgendwie schön aus und so ist ne
zu halten naja ich muss so lange wie ich
kann
die hat auch ich bin leicht angeschlagen
ich sprechen bisschen nasaal wir waren
am Wochenende auch noch in Belgien es
ging total viel ab bei mir in den
letzten Monaten auch mit so vielen
Projekten ich mache auch einiges mit
Immobilien was ihr gar nicht so
mitbekommt
wo an jeder Ecke irgendwelche Baustellen
sind das ist ja keine Ahnung ich will
mich auch nicht beschweren wie gesagt um
Gottes Willen allerdings ist es für mich
halt immer so wenn ich in den Urlaub
fahre beispielsweise für 7 Tage dann
habe ich normal die ganze Zeit meinen
Stress ich bin ja egal ob jetzt Montags
morgens oder Samstag nachmittags oder
sonntags abends ich bin ja immer
irgendwie am Videos machen schneiden in
Social Media Kram zu machen ich habe
immer so mein normalen Stress und wenn
ich weiß ich bin bei 7 Tage im Urlaub
heißt das für mich die 7 Tage davor
doppelt so viele produzieren um dann
sieben Tage abzuschalten
und das und das equals genau wieder die
normalen Stress das halt das Problem und
bei einer normalen Festanstellung von
einem Freund zum Beispiel ist es halt so
die haben Urlaubsanspruch und sind
normal am arbeiten dann haben sie
irgendwie reichen Urlaub an und dann
machen oder wenn man eine Pause und das
ist dann total gut bei mir ist aber
immer so ich habe immer so eine so eine
Anstieg vom Stress und dann wieder gar
keinen Stress haben echt nicht gut für
den Körper nicht gut für psychisch nicht
gut fürs Herz ich achte sehr auf meine
Gesundheit eigentlich klar
aber so im groben und ganzen ist ja dass
ich eigentlich ein sehr recht gesund
lebender Mensch bin unterwegs auch weiß
wie wichtig ist dass man auf seinen
Körper achtet und das ist für mich
einfach jetzt wieder so ein Zeichen
gewesen ey Luca nimmt dich ein bisschen
zurück
das heißt jetzt nicht dass keine Videos
kommen auf dem zweitkanal geht alles
basically genauso weiter wie geplant ist
wie gesagt auch alles unter der
Beschreibung verlinkt schaut er gern
vorbei auf Youtube Channel aber auf dem
Hauptkanal komm mal wirklich nur so alle
paar Tage ab jetzt Videos für die
nächsten zwei drei Wochen ich habe ein
bisschen was vor produziert ein bisschen
was ist geplant aber dieses Video dient
euch einfach nur kurz hier als Info
dafür dass
[Musik]
ja ich halt einfach so ein bisschen
merke ich brauche meine Pause und ich
freue mich da extrem drauf ich habe zwei
drei Bücher mitgenommen ich freue mich
einfach auf Strandkorb sitzen chillen
entspannen und dann zurückkommen und
frisch durchgeatmet zu sein frisch und
fit zu sein und da freue ich mich
einfach extrem drauf deswegen ähm das
nur ein ganz kurzes Infovideo
diesbezüglich ähm
ja es wird wie gesagt keine richtige
Pause sein aber es kommt halt deutlich
weniger und ich fühle mich dann immer so
blöd wenn ich dann weniger hochladen
welchen Urlaub bin und so weil ich liebe
ja eigentlich auch meinen Job ich liebe
ich liebe das auch zu arbeiten so dumm
das klingt aber ja das nur für euch zu
Erklärung ich hoffe euch geht's gut
achtet auf eurem Körper wir sehen uns
wenn ich zurück bin oder halt die
nächsten Tage oder auf dem zweiten Kanal
es kommen mir ein paar Videos wie gesagt
aber das nur für euch zur Info dieses
Video lösche